I'm actually um missing therapy to be
here so I really need this to go well
i-i'll of therapy I think therapy's
great I think everyone should be in
therapy everyone should be in therapy
don't do it for yourself do it for your
friends they don't want to hear that
[ __ ] anymore if you think you don't need
therapy here's what I want you to do
tell your best friend that you're
thinking about it
see how relieved they look I came an
aunt recently a new my sister did most
of the work it's cool you know I really
thought that my parents loved me until
they became grandparents and it turns
out they were giving me about 50% I know
what their love looks like now it's a
new thing I hadn't seen before
frankly it's dazzling it's cool he's
very cute we've got a photo stream on
our phones for pictures of the baby
anytime my sister takes a picture of the
baby she adds it to the photo stream we
all get a notification there's a new
picture of the baby if we hang out with
a baby we can add a picture that's not
what I've been using it for
what I like to do is I like to upload
pictures of myself doing just whatever
the baby was doing in the last picture
but like a little bit better you might I
mean like with more dexterity but he's
cuter than me I will give him that but I
put the triangle block right in the
triangle hole first try no this is
banging around on the box
raising kits seems really hard which is
why I am all in favor of putting your
kid on a leash if you want to it gets a
bad rap but put your kid on a leash I
don't care I've never seen a kid on a
leash who didn't need that leash I'm
gonna mean the leashes always pulled
taut always reaching for a stranger's
mouth put your kid on a leash I don't
care I don't understand a single
argument against it people are like I
don't want to put my kid on a leash
because I want him to explore I want him
to be an explorer
you guys know explorers history's worst
monsters why would we encourage that
behavior maybe maybe of Columbus's mom
had put him on a leash as a kid he
wouldn't have spent his adulthood Jenna
citing everyone teach boundaries young
people are like what happens when you
take the kid off the leash and then they
go crazy and to that I say I'm not gonna
be there then we're all at the airport
now
I'm not saying you have to put your kid
on a leash I'm just saying if someone
else wants to do it cut them some slack
which by the way is a phrase we got from
leashes it was it was a rough election I
think we all agree on that
I really think Donald Trump was the air
bud of this election but I also think
that Air Bud was the villain of that
movie I'll explain imagine for a moment
that you're one of the kids on the other
basketball team like you're one of the
kids who has to play basketball against
a golden retriever you're just a kid who
loves basketball right you've been
practicing basketball you know the rules
of basketball you showed up to the gym
that day expecting to play another child
at basketball that's Hillary Clinton
right she's just been like put me in
coach for the last ten years and we
finally did and then this freakin fluffy
dog who has no business on the court
comes running out distracting everybody
he doesn't know the rules he can't know
the rules he is a dog he's travelling
like crazy where's the ref and
everyone's just fine with it because
there's nothing in the rulebook that
says a pumpkin-headed reality TV star
can't be President let's write more
rules what are we waiting for
also I should say I have not seen Air
Bud together pretty well
[Applause]
you